i did want to talk about the bachelor
final episode and i realized why the
[ __ ] do i bother you know people don't
get it i am so
outraged that this bachelor ended up
with this gorgeous woman susie
i had such hope for her i thought she
was so bright and i can't believe women
aren't more up in arms over what this
bachelor pulled in what did he do
he has three women at the end it's time
for the fantasy sweep yeah each woman
before the fantasy suite he goes i'm in
love with you i just i had to i have to
say it i'm in love with you well these
women are like oh my god he's my dream
man he loves me
we're done the third one susie went you
know what i think he might be [ __ ]
these women
and he's on there going i can't help it
i'm in love with three women but i love
susie the most now if when you love
someone you can't love someone the most
the guy was a monster
and it ended up at the end of the season
she overlooked everything to susie
and she she went listen to this [ __ ]
guy he's playing these women and and and
i thought susie was going to dump him
and you've really allowed me
to get there as well because i was so
afraid
and you know because of that
um you know i've i've
realized that like
you know i'm falling in love with you
i am
i really am and it wasn't just like
something i came to today i had these
feelings i just wasn't allowing myself
to like admit it so the woman's saying
of course i'm gonna go in the fantasy
suite and [ __ ] him he's telling me he's
in love with me and that's it the game's
over that's what he's i'm the one and
then here he is with the second one i've
kind of come to terms like with what i
am feeling
um
and i kind of wish i had told you
earlier i'm falling in love with you
i am and
i have been he's just scared
i
realized that i had been feeling this
way for probably a couple weeks i knew
he [ __ ] the other girl tonight if not
more and told her the same thing part of
me was scared because i hadn't felt
those feelings for over five or six
years since my last relationship
so thank you for being patient with me
he's screaming he's in love with them
and there's susie says uh hey by the way
did you have sex with the other two
and he goes i had sex with one of them
like he even
lied he lies yeah yeah he goes well uh
or maybe i had sex with two uh he goes
but i love you the most i love you the
most and she goes wait a second you love
me the most but you [ __ ] the other two
women
well he got so angry with her he goes
yeah you leave i have nothing more to
say there's nothing more i don't
anything you say to me at this point
doesn't matter anymore and so i'm just
gonna walk you out and just
i'm done
and he throws her into the car i mean i
was like
what the [ __ ]
and she
and now she's waiting back she came back
to him i was outraged